σε έχουν πρότυπο θέλου να σκοληθύμου την ατιοπλοία ίσω κάπου φοβούνται να καταφέρουν θα έχου
δπλατους τους αρμόδιους φορείς πιο μήνημαστε λέο παύλος τους νέους το μι τους τέλνε ότι
η πάντος δεν να προσπαεί ν πριν ει στο κανοντίς εκαότά από το είνα αυτός
ου να αγαπάζ αυτόν που κάνεις γιατί σκεφτείται αν η δυνατογηδες μας είναι μέχριεδώ και
στο χεύσουμε μέχρι εδώ ιαν ρευτούμε μέχριεδ πολύ πιθανών να περάσουμε έ αυτόν ου έχουμε
στο εύσκι αλλά πολύ πηθανών όμως να μη φθάσουμε κάν το εκατούν τις εκατόν του
καπάσει δή μας άν όμως στο εύσουμε και ενιρευτούμε των νανών με μαθηματική να κριβά
θα ξεπεράσουμε τις διαναδοηθες μας αλλά δεν ξέρο να θα φτάσουμε υτό που έχουμε ενευτεί
όχι σημασίν όμως δεν έχει γι ανθατο φτάσει ση μασίανα έχει να ξέρεις ότι έδωσης
των καθω τουσε αυτόν γιατί στο κατοκάτο τέλος τις ημέρας αν το κάνειςε αυτόν καθημερινά
μπορεί να δίστν ατόσ στων καθρέφτην και να πεισε έκανω ότι κανέδρο μπορούσ να από
μια α έτσι μικρή στορία σ αυτόν πριν κλείσουμε το δώ δκα πρ πριν τους
οιναό το δέκα λέγα στη μετερα μο ότι θέλω να βάλωε επαύσητες πουδασμό για να
φωσιοτεό πλήρος τους όλι μιακούσαγόνες για ανάειμε όσε ο πιο έτοιμος μπορώ και αυτί μου
έλεγι ενόχι πολε να κανεις όλα στην αρχή όταν τις εξήγησα ότι λπα γινα κάθεθε
στα χρόνια δεσόρχοντε υκαιρίες και ότι όλι είαι πάγρματιές κάμε μόν αυτόν τον πράγμα και
ότιις το τέως τις ημέρας θέλω να δών πάύλος των καθρφττη κια να του πω
έκανες ότι καδρον μπορούσες ανεξάρτει από τοέλεσμα τότε έγινε οι καέδρο μου σύμαχος και τη
στιγκιωνιά πουζούμε θα εκτιικηθεί για λλιά ένας άλλο να πει όχι μα γιατί όλοινα κάνωπαύσυν
τες πουδέςμου ακου για τα αρνητικώ άμαμε αναλογιστεί στο λόγο νόμως που είχε καύσηνες πουδές
και στο τέλος τι ακολούθησε τότε τώρα είναι όλοι πράβο τα κατάφερς οι γωνείς ν
εσύμαχι στα παιδιά τους γιατί θα δουν και πολύ γωνείς αυτό το βίτεο